varios peruanos han muerto en este país
por las protestas tras la institución de
Pedro Castillo diversos colectivos
sociales acusan a la presidenta a Dina
boluarte de haber criminalizado las
protestas y estar supuestamente más
preocupada por la economía que por los
fallecidos estos hechos han motivado las
renuncias de la ministra de Educación
Patricia Correa y el ministro de cultura
Jair Pérez ambos señalan que la crisis
demanda el respeto al orden Ya la vez a
la integridad física y la vida de los
peruanos que lamentablemente se han
visto vulneradas y las muertes en los
disturbios hacen insostenible su
participación en el gobierno de Dina
boluarte precisamente dos abogados han
denunciado penalmente por presuntos
delitos de genocidio y homicidio a la
mandataria peruana y a sus ministros por
las muertes en las protestas en paralelo
la fiscalía ha iniciado investigaciones
preliminares contra los presuntos
responsables Mientras tanto la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
enviará una delegación a este país del
19 al 21 de diciembre aceptando una
invitación del Estado peruano mientras
se programa otra visita de un relator
para mediados de enero del 2023 en medio
de esta situación crítica que viven los
peruanos El Congreso de sanación rechazó
el proyecto de adelanto de elecciones 49
legisladores votaron a favor 33 en
contra y 25 se obtuvieron la reforma
requería 87 votos para después ser
ratificada en una segunda legislatura o
66 votos para ser consultada en
referéndum diversos analistas culpan a
los congresistas de derecha a izquierda
por priorizar sus intereses personales a
los intereses del Perú y los peruanos en
estos momentos difíciles